hi there Steve Kaufman here and today I
want to talk about what holds people
back from learning languages last night
we had some guests here I have my cousin
visiting from Argentina which is where
she lives but she has a very good
girlfriend here in Vancouver and they
came over for dinner and this girlfriend
of hers said that you know she's now I
guess in her early 50s and she really
wants to learn French and Spanish and
she says a lot of her friends also want
to learn the language and travel in
those countries and of course many
people say this and many people never
take the necessary steps to make it
happen and so my question is like what
holds these people back and in the
conversation I had with this lady last
night you know it was obvious to me that
that she's held that backed by a lot of
unfounded fears and misconceptions she
said first of all you know well I'm old
now I find that I'm forgetting things
I'm she's 15 years younger than I am I
would imagine I forget things I have a
poor memory I have trouble with
pronunciation I don't know all kinds of
reasons why you know and and most people
when they go when they decide they want
to learn the language they decide they
have to go to a class well it takes a
lot of money time commitment to go to a
class typically it's just not two
minutes away you've got to drive to it
or take public transportation you're
sitting in a classroom with other people
which is fun which is social and I think
to that extent going into a class can be
a pleasant social thing to do if if your
goal is to meet people then then that's
a great thing to do but if the goal is
to learn the language you don't need to
go to a class you know I've been at my
check now for a couple of months and I'm
reading the newspaper with difficulty if
I had started check-in a class after two
months I'd be nowhere
I wouldn't be very far along not as far
along as I am and it would have meant a
disruption to my schedule I don't have
the time to go in the evenings or even
during the day and sit in the classroom
and learning Czech so it you know it
reminded me you know Anna and I happen
to receive a copy of this book written
by cattle mom who's a very famous
Hungarian polyglot linguist as I prefer
to call him who spoke sixteen languages
and her method of learning was very much
through input reading and listening she
didn't have the benefit of the Internet
but she had she lived in in communist
Hungary for most of the period when she
was learning languages so she had
limited access to material but whenever
she got her hands on a book or something
she would read it now she probably has
more determination and motivation than
the average person but the fact remains
that we can all learn through input and
capital mom makes the case that that
it's not a matter of talent it's a
matter of hard work one other thing you
know I'm kind of talking about some of
the obstacles some of the misconceptions
that people have
I don't think language learning is hard
work I don't think it's unpleasant work
it needn't be it takes a lot of time but
it can be done in a way that's pleasant
and relatively painless and I always
prefer the easy painless way that's why
for example when I get a book for
learning a language unlike Catalan I
don't do the exercises because I find
that hard work I just listen and read
and eventually things stick and it just
you know if only people would realize
that by by listening to and reading
content of interest and building up
their comprehension their language
skills will improve and people say well
I need someone to talk to what you're
sure you do eventually but you can't
talk to someone if you don't understand
what they're saying so the first step is
to build up your comprehension and that
again gets back to this input based
learning
listening and reading and you talk when
you have the opportunity and the better
you understand and the more words you
have the better you'll be able to take
advantage of the opportunity when the
opportunity presents itself I would just
note it down some of the other things
that people say yeah one of the other
sort of mix about language learning is
that you first have the pep to sort of
get down the fundamentals I think
someone came out beyond my youtube
channel and so first you have to have
the fundamentals you know that's one
thing that I simply don't believe
because the fundamentals you're
constantly acquiring the fundamentals
you're constantly learning and
forgetting certain things that in fact
are perhaps quite fundamental you don't
grasp them initially you don't grasp
them till much much later so that this
it's a very gradual process you it's not
like fundamentals like like building
blocks that you learn the tenses and you
learn the cases there's a Russian or
tenses in French and then that's a
building block upon which you build you
know more and more knowledge until
eventually you have this big structure
which is your capability of French it's
not like that at all you will continue
to make mistakes in tenses in French you
will continue to get mistakes and make
mistakes in masculine-feminine just as I
hear Chinese speakers continue to make
mistakes with he obscene and they speak
English you will continue to make the
most basic fundamental mistakes for a
long long time no matter how much it's
drilled into you and gradually if you
keep at it and if you enjoy what you're
doing and you know again the Trinity if
you're motivated you spend the time and
you start to notice if you begin to
become a little attentive to the
language all these things gradually
you'll get better so it's a process of
gradual improvement rather than one of
having nailing down some fundamentals
and building other fundamentals on top
of you'll always be making the most
fundamental mistakes for a long long
time if you're not prepared to do that
and you shouldn't learn but if you're
prepared to enjoy the pleasure of
communicating in another language
understanding other people in their
language understanding movies understand
songs enjoying exploring and other
culture and language if you're content
to do all those things and still make
the odd mistake when you speak then
language learning is for you if you
think you have to nail down something
right away you're gonna be very
disappointed and you won't make much
progress in my opinion
so what other notes that I have I can't
remember but my advice to people and now
there must be millions of people in
their 50s who have a little more time
who would like to travel who would like
to explore either virtually by learning
a language or physically by first
learning a language and then going to
the country where the language is spoken
just do it just start and take the easy
route it's the easy way around it's not
it's not instant because language
learning takes time but it's not hard
it doesn't require some amazing talent
that it requires perseverance a lot of
listening and reading day after day
after day and building up your
vocabulary so I mentioned this because I
think there are a lot of myths out there
about what you need to do to learn a
language the kind of skill or talent
that you have to have in order to learn
a lot of language the core sort of steps
that you have to follow and I personally
don't believe that I think that if you
commit yourself to a program of daily
listening and reading anyone like I've
done with check anyone that is prepared
to spend the time that I have spent
listening and reading to a language that
the time that I spent on check after two
months they will achieve a lot
guaranteed okay so thank you and I look
forward to your comments